great why don't we
go ahead and get started i want to
welcome everyone to the
um first well actually no i guess it's
the second
session of our thursday research
conference for the fall
quarter which we plan to
continue like usual during this pandemic
even though in a
uh different and probably less
fun format i'd personally rather be
standing in front of you all in the bic
theater
but i will not be doing that today
i uh usually when i'm at the conference
i always introduce the speaker but i
am the speaker so i'll introduce myself
briefly when i start
um and i think as uh those of you who
have been around
know um i give this talk
um every year i've been doing it for a
number of years running now
where i give an overview of the state of
the program and the state of the field
and so i'm going to use some slides and
once i do that
i'll have less view because of the way
that
um webex works i'll have less view
but if if anyone has any questions and i
i will try to leave some time for
questions
please type them into the chat box and
then when i finish my slides
which should hopefully take no more than
40 minutes at the most
i'll i'll try to go through as many
questions as i can
i also note that we have some guests
here today uh every fall we have an
annual
open house and we invite
um uh and and we invite uh people who
may be interested in studying in the
program
and so there are attendees of our open
house
who can uh optionally attend this talk
and um they also spent the last hour
going through some virtual poster
sessions including a couple i was
involved with
um it's again it's not quite the same as
standing in front of a poster but
um it did give us a chance to uh show
our research and and engage
um and then when this session is over um
there will be the main open house
session that will start with the
presentation by myself
um and then others including um ted
harris and um i think andrea and diane
and so forth so i'm going to go ahead
and share my
slides
and i guess if
[Music]
if anyone has any trouble let
let me know you should be seeing my uh
initial slide which says state of the
program state of the field and
as most of you know i'm bill hirsch i'm
chair of the department of medical
informatics and clinical epidemiology
we're a department in the school of
medicine
at ohsu so
um as the title says state of the
program state of the field i'll
give an overview of the program
including the department
research we do education some comments
on faculty and staff
and then um that'll be about half the
talk then the other half
just some of the highlights of the field
where things are and what a difference a
year makes um
we um were uh in a very different
situation a year ago
uh before the pandemic
so any issues hearing me or i thought i
heard some noise
okay i'll keep going um so
you all know uh we are the department of
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology d
mice we are an academic department in
the
ohsu school of medicine providing
leadership discovery and dissemination
of knowledge
in our three stated areas
we're an academic department so we
mostly focus on research and education
we are a well-known department in our
fields in the informatics field
in the clinical epidemiology field
around the country in the world
and we have a website that has a vanity
url
that you can click to um as well as a
blog
which we're always looking for good
content to post
so um this has been a challenging year
for the department for the university
for all of us
as we transition to remote work i do
occasionally go up to the fifth floor of
the bic
um there's not much going on there
and um we've made this transition to
remote work
because we work with computers and we do
a lot of online teaching already
we've pretty much been able to continue
our activity
and though we do plenty of in-person
things including teaching
and that all has moved to online as well
our department finances are actually
quite strong we met our budget targets
last year
um the faculty and and
ua staff went through a salary reduction
that
has been restored um the university's
finances
are um stable enough that the leadership
is confident to restore salaries to
their previous levels
um there was also a rise in tuition
which we
really did not want to see and
fortunately that has been reduced back
to a small
rise at this point informatics despite
our work is really a people field
i think all of us enjoy the interactions
with people
and um i i've said to a number of people
including a number of you i could not
imagine going through this pandemic
without the internet without social
media
keeping in touch with friends and
colleagues and family and so forth
so um while again i um
would prefer to be in a room with you
all instead of on webex here
um we are uh able to keep in touch in
in various ways so
um i usually show a variant of this
slide and i always have to thank
catherine
pyle for helping with the data
just to show you our research
productivity research isn't all about
funding and publications but you need
those to actually do the research
um we we've had uh we had a phenomenal
year last year
i think some of it was due to covid some
people were able to
get research projects funded related to
covid um
and um actually i thought you see the
last
big bump in our research funding that
was the last economic recession
it's it's unfortunate that it takes um
economic turmoil uh
for us to um uh uh bump up our research
funding but
um we're almost this year um we were
over 15 million dollars in grant funding
across the department
um and um actually that should say total
external funding
97 to 2020. um uh
oh dmice over the years uh since we were
previously a freestanding division now
department um has received 177 million
dollars in research funding
um we um have a strong
publication record um i guess maybe
this past year we were a little too busy
writing grant proposals so our number of
publications slightly tapered off but we
we had a lot of good publications um
including in some of the
um top uh journals in the field
um and we have a very good uh grant
proposal funding rate um
the nih rate as some of you might know
is about 15 to 20 percent
we do considerably better than that um
maybe just because we're strategic we
also have a great grants proposal
process
again catherine um is the lead on that
and and is one of the major reasons why
we're so successful
and we're last year was a record number
of proposals
um many of you listening submitted those
proposals myself included and we we've
even continued off into this year
our educational programs are robust
we have been funded by our national
library medicine training grant since
1992
i've actually been here that long i i've
not been the pi the original pi was
dr robert beck the original occupant of
my office
but um our nlm training grant is the
largest
and second longest running training
grant
at the entire university and um
this year i thought it was going to be
really fun to
for the second time host the nlm
trainees meeting
and um of course it too ended up needing
to be virtual
we did learn a lot about putting on
virtual meetings but unfortunately
didn't get to show people the wonderful
weather
in early june or maybe later june
the tuesday farmers market and all that
but
such such was life our graduate program
in biomedical informatics has been
around since 1996
we started the phd program in 2003
we've been teaching online and are known
for our innovation and teaching that way
since 1999
around 2005 we took my introductory
bmi 510 course and turned it into
something called
10 by 10 which has more of a continuing
education type course that's been
completed now by almost 2 700 people
some of whom have gone on to do graduate
study in our program
we've got a number of educational grants
from the office of the national
coordinator bd2k we have a few
that are in the hopper being evaluated
we're involved in uh education for other
programs outside of people who are
studying to work in informatics so
medical students since 2013 uh we've
also been teaching basic science
students
um and others paul gorman has uh
probably spearheaded although actually
many of us are involved in teaching
the medical students we were also one of
the first
programs in the country when clinical
informatics became a
sub specialty for physicians so it's
informatics is not only for physicians
but there are parts of it that are for
physicians
including this subspecialty of clinical
informatics
we were one of the first in the country
to get accredited to have a fellowship
program accredited by acgme
and in fact other there's about 46
programs now
and um several other programs actually
use our online courses and vishnu mohan
directs
the fellowship program because we have
such a large alumnus
alumni i will i'll talk about that in a
little bit
we've also gotten into the business of
continuing education
for informatics professionals physicians
others in the field and last year we
launched our first annual update in
clinical informatics
that enrolled 185 people and the second
annual offering will start later this
month or early next month
um the our program has a wide reach
and many distinguished alumni um
for those of you who've been around
you've seen the numbers in that table
and the upper right
grow over the years we've awarded
graduate certificates masters phds
we've awarded them in the two tracks bio
bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine and health and clinical
informatics
there's a about 70 or so people
because some people have more than one
uh of
of these and um we keep in touch with
our alumni
um we're proud of their work in fact
right below it is a
bookcase that sits right behind diane's
desk
outside my office on the fifth floor of
the book it's still there
that has actually this only has um some
of the
theses and dissertations that our
students have done over the years and so
we've been a very productive bunch
on the left hand side is a slide that
shows where our
online students live you can see they
live all over the country maybe a little
bit more concentrated in the northwest
but
all over the country and of course we
enjoy being an international program
we've had particular programs with
groups in singapore thailand and
argentina
but we've had students from literally
all over the world
um asia africa
europe south america and and elsewhere
and and that i think most of us really
enjoy
that international connection um uh
this is our current enrollment um
so um uh we it has the phd students uh
our two masters programs thesis and
non-thesis and graduate certificate
in the two majors as we call them now
bcb and hcin and so our enrollment
continues strong
even fortunately through the pandemic
we also have um i guess i'm biased but
i would argue one of the most
accomplished informatics faculty
anywhere in the country or the world in
fact
they're so large and so accomplished
that there's no way i can mention
everyone um and i apologize in advance
because i'm going to mention some but
not others
just to call out a few specific things
the complete list of faculty is on our
website
and i encourage you to visit there
especially if you're a student
potentially thinking of trying to find a
mentor for a project
you can see the interests and
accomplishments of the faculty
many of our faculty have um leadership
roles beyond the department
and um um most of you
many of you know these individuals david
dorr continues to serve as chief
research and this is an alphabetical
order
chief research information officer crio
karen eden is president of the faculty
senate
paul gorman has a number of leadership
roles in the
medical school curriculum shannon
mcqueeny is director of computational
biomedicine for the knight cancer
institute among many other
things that she does
vishnu mohan in addition to directing
our fellowship was
is now past chair of the clinical
informatics program directors
and cindy morris who's heavily involved
in
oak tree the oregon clinical and
translational research institute
and also the exodus build program which
is a program that aims to attract
historically underrepresented minorities
at portland state
into biomedical research careers
i also point out that for the six
individuals on this slide david
karen shannon and cindy
are also the serve as the vice
chairs of the department and they're
part of the executive committee along
with ann marshall our
department director
um it's always important for an academic
program to
have um young faculty
up and coming and we're very proud of
the fact that michelle rybar lisa
carstens nicole weiskopf and dana womack
all have career development awards uh
k awards or or in the case of michelle
are our double zero
um and um they're already at work
um actually some of them have have
gotten new grants funded to move beyond
the career development awards and others
are in the process of
of heading down that path um so
this is where i'm just going to call out
a few faculty again
i apologize for not mentioning everyone
i always like to mention
people who are new to the department
and again these are in alphabetical
order
chris alpe many of you know she
regularly attends this conference i
can't see whether or not she's here
when i go back to my full screen i will
chris
is the director of the ohsu library um
and is uh um very active in the
informatics community
and um also has now a faculty
appointment in d mice
chris hoekstra recently uh completed our
phd
program and has a background in physical
therapy
has joined us in a part-time role
in teaching anita walden
joins the um clinical data to health
project i'm actually going to mention
that later when i talk about
things going on in the informatics field
and and dr lauren walker who
comes as a pediatrics infectious disease
physician
but also um with has done work in
informatics and joins our department
i apologize i i went through the list i
think these are the only four new people
but
uh you can remind me in the chat box if
i missed anyone
two other people who are not new at all
um to d mice but um now have their
primary academic appointments with us
coming from the dissolution of the
center for spoken language understanding
um steve bedrick who received his phd in
our program
and shubo song who
works in imaging informatics so they've
joined our faculty
we had three promotions this year dr
melissa handel
promoted to professor and um shelley
self and guam ming wu promoted to
associate professor
and we've won some awards there's
probably more i apologize if i
uh have missed any but um dr ted ladaris
uh won the sakai torch bearer award and
and ted is well known for his work
in um teaching r
and making his uh curricular materials
available in an open science
manner very prolific in that regard
of course dmice is a team
obviously the faculty play a critical
role but the faculty would not succeed
if not for the staff and and let me also
mention that for those faculty who i
didn't mention
maybe they'll be willing to give a talk
in the conference during the year
and you can hear about their research we
have
our departmental staff ann marshall
mursada guild
our financial person who unfortunately
is leaving for a job in the dean's
office
alicia nam katherine pyle who i already
mentioned who
also teaches and is part of the faculty
and monica garlow
our educational staff andrea ill diane
doctor
lauren ludwig lynn schwabe virginia
lankes and kate fultz hollis who
is heads up the los angeles
office of ohsu and there's some others
around
the department who support research
associates others who support
individual faculty and projects and of
course our students and fellows is
certainly the main reason why we're here
everyone enjoys and is passionate about
education and it's such a major part of
the department
um so if you attend this conference on a
regular basis you get to hear our
students presenting
maybe even defending their work at this
meeting
also presenting at things like the nlm
trainees meetings and other meetings
such as the amia meeting
and of course they make incredibly
important contributions to the research
teaching and other activities
um it's been a pretty good year for
myself so i'll give myself
one slide to brag a little bit some of
you may know
there's a new honorific society for
informatics
that's part of the international medical
informatics association called the
international academy of health sciences
informatics it was formed in 2017. i was
part of the inaugural
class and
was elected as the second president of
the academy
so that that will consume some of my
time in the next couple years
you also know that i like to write
especially about things like information
retrieval
it had been a long time coming but i
finally
just recently published the fourth
edition of my book
which if you're inside the ohsu network
you can download
um at no charge it's part of springer
link
and if you want to catch up on the
latest in information retrieval in
biomedicine and health you can do that
um i've also been active
during the pandemic
i and colleagues from nist and
university of texas houston
and the allen institute put together
this
information retrieval challenge
evaluation
um over the some of you may be familiar
with the cord 19 data set that the allen
institute has developed and so that's um
taken a fair amount of my time this year
so um
okay so that's that's the state of the
program
uh let me make a few comments about a
state of the field
if you went to this talk last year you
remember then i got that i got up and
said these are the three hot topics in
informatics
machine learning and artificial
intelligence data science etc
data interoperability with the proposed
21st century cures rule
and work done by amia characterizing the
professional work of informatics mainly
on the health and clinical side
these three topics are all still vitally
important
but something else happened along the
way which is covid19
so i'll i'll just have one slide each
for these topics so
machine learning and ai continue to be
critically
important and they will continue to be
important
i think the big challenges is how they
will impact
healthcare and biomedicine and also i
think
some of the issues that we're now
learning around data and biases and data
and and so forth and i'll i'll talk
about that topic in the context of covet
19.
but there's so many um studies now
especially in
imaging that people are doing systematic
reviews
and these systems work about as
effectively
as human experts with good
training however
there are some limitations first of all
the the
the research studies tend to be done
with well-curated high-quality data sets
that may not be realistic uh or
validated
um and people don't always report
their methods as well as they should so
not have challenges with being
reproducible
the the the real big step for machine
learning and ai
is their application in the real world
people have written articles saying that
we need meaningful evaluation it's one
thing to
to show something works in a data set
it's a different matter
to work in a healthcare system that many
of these systems especially deep
learning systems are black boxes we need
some way for the algorithms to explain
their output since we may be making
decisions about patients
um we also need reporting guidelines and
some of the
well-known clinical trials guidelines
are being adapted for ai
there's a number of ethical issues in
terms of how these systems are applied
and they also require clinical
validation and i'll uh maybe
to to my own horn again here although
it's really the work of aaron cohen
um but um it's a challenge to um
get irb approval get clinicians to buy
and and so forth when you want to
validate um a finding for example the
finding
that aaron and i spoke about last year
in this conference in in acute
intermittent porphyria
and and hopefully we'll be able to start
moving forward to see
if identifying patients who may have
this disease indeed may
actually have it and when you move into
the clinical realm there's a lot more
challenges um the the um
in terms of data standard the 21st
century cures rule
um has been released um it enshrines
um smart on fire which many of you know
about
um is uh standard for for apps and for
moving
uh clinical data securely around the
internet
um uh there's um
the rule also has uh uh regulations
around easy export of data
for for single patients as well as whole
ehr systems
this whole issue of information blocking
which would probably require an hour to
talk about um and some of the timelines
have been delayed
um the rules been released but some of
the timelines in terms of required
implementation have pushed back
have been pushed back although that's
unfortunate because it actually would
have been helpful
to have the 21st century cures rule
in place and and all of the standards in
place
uh before covet 19 came but that didn't
happen
um but this will like machine learning
will continue to be important
as will
the work of of informatics professionals
again i don't really have time to go
into this other than
we know a lot more now about what
those who work in informatics do in
their jobs
the tasks the knowledge and skills that
they require
these have been published and um
they're in addition to the physician
certification there's going to be
um certification beyond physicians um
probably the main point to learn from
this huge analysis
is that um there used to be four domains
basically
fundamental knowledge enhance the
clinical decision making information
systems and
and management leadership and now
there's a fifth domain
domain number four on the slide here
around data governance and analytics
just
recognizing the importance of data in
the work that we do
okay see here
[Music]
um so um as i said
um what's really hot this year is
is covet 19. and um so again i'm just
going to touch
on some very high level topics and i
know that a number
of you all are involved in projects and
um
doing work to enhance the response to
covet 19.
um clearly covet 19 shows that we not
only need that
those data standards but really the
national um
health i.t infrastructure many of you
know dean siddik who used to be on our
faculty
and has written a lot about that
we need to balance privacy versus access
there are large data sets being created
there's great efforts being made to
protect privacy but we know that there
can sometimes be challenges and
re-identification of data
but it's critically important to get
access to that data
so we can identify better diagnostics
better treatments and so forth
um that then leads to the whole issue of
speed um of getting
evidence out into the hands of
clinicians
where we may need to compromise the
purity
um although for those who follow the
news know there's a lot of discussion
going on about
how good of clinical trials and other
things we need to do
for things like vaccines and monoclonal
antibodies and so forth
um and then what about the role of ai
the role of ai has actually been
relatively limited i know there are some
applications but but one of the
reasons for the success of ai is we have
data that enable us to
learn from it and of course um
everything about covet
not everything a lot of things about
covet 19 are new
and so a number of people have written
that so far
the contribution of ai machine learning
and so forth has been small though there
are some
um applications um
this is a nice paper and actually by the
way my my slides
are on my website and i'll give you the
url for that so
um you can i always put my references in
these slides
this is a nice paper that looked at all
of the digital technologies for covet
19.
there you see things like machine
learning mobile apps
um digital diagnostics and genomics
and and things like social media
syndromic surveillance and so forth so
there
there's a lot of potential applications
of informatics and and a number of ones
that have been occurring
um you all or those of you who who
attended last week
heard the talk on telemedicine so i'm
not going to really go into it in much
detail
um only other than to point out that
um telemedicine was formerly a pretty
rare thing
um in fact i myself annette totten
um karen eden dana womack and others um
have been involved in
evidence reports around telemedicine and
of course as you all know the use of
telemedicine
um changed overnight um and this
graph from from ohsu shows
the the rapid rise at the onset of the
pandemic in virtual visits
even in telephone visits um
and part of this was enabled by the
federal response so
the centers for medicare medicaid
services forced
formerly had very tight restrictions on
reimbursement for telehealth services
they basically opened it up to
essentially everything
no longer did you have to be an
established patient it didn't have to be
in a rural area and so forth
and also the federal government um uh
backed up on hipaa um for example
you used to not be able to use things
like facetime or or non-secure text
messaging things like that
and you had to have business associate
agreements with everyone
um uh the government stepped back from
that
to make sure that that telemedicine
could be
um uh rolled out quickly
um we so we heard about telemedicine
last week we'll hear more about
the projects in the next few slides or
one in particular hopefully in the near
future i'm trying to get them to
uh come give us a talk um but there have
been a number of large um research data
collection efforts probably the most
prominent
in the u.s is the n3c project
which is one of the leaders is dr
melissa hendell from
our faculty from d mice who recently
published a paper
and jamie about it and it's a nationwide
effort
um a lot through the uh academic medical
centers that are part of the
nih ctsa award
um program and um
there's um large data sets becoming
available
ohsu is contributing data ohsu
will be able to make data requests by
the process i'll talk about in a moment
but i'm i'm
hoping that the n3c leadership uh
in the department will come back and
give a full talk
um there's other international efforts
some of you may be familiar with the
odyssey project
which i actually don't have that listed
uh
the name listed here but they're part of
the consortium for clinical
characterization of covet 19
or 4ce um george ripsack
um our colleague from columbia is among
the leadership for that
and and other projects in other
countries um
i'm particularly uh impressed by the
open safely project in the uk
where they've been able to tap into
their database of 24 million
primary care patients so that's about a
third of the population
and then connect that with coven 19 data
i'll show you an example of it in a
moment
so let's talk a little bit about n3c
again just a high level overview um n3c
brings together a number of um existing
products the
projects the cd2h
project here of which ohsu
is is one of the nine centers and uh dr
handel in the lead
and the ctsa program the goal of this
is to build a centralized resource for
the country for the united states of lab
confirmed suspected and possible
cases of coven 19 and building on a lot
of
initiatives so i stole this slide off
their website
that shows um things you see odyssey
there
i2b2 p cornet and then you see the
hl7 fire truck going down the middle
because the data is all standards-based
so um basically those who participate
in n3c enter into a data use agreement
which has to go through the
institutional irb
they can then load data into the data
enclave
so the data is a centralized resource
it's
protected and
in order to use it you have to fill out
a data use request you have to have
various research trainings
and your projects get approved um
interestingly enough there's three
levels of data
there's the hipaa safe harbor which is
the most
um it doesn't really it has
some identifiers that that are part of
phi
protected health information um so you
you have to
get the most um or i'm sorry that's the
i'm sorry i got that wrong
that's the limited data set the one at
the bottom the hipaa safe harbor
is fully de-identified the limited data
set is mostly de-identified but has
potential for re-identification
um and then they're also creating a
synthetic data set
that that won't be real patient data but
it'll have the characteristics of the
real patient data
obviously it will be there'll be more
hoops to jump through to get
to the limited data set than the say the
synthetic data set and all the data will
need to be used in the
enclave there's a phenotyping
that has been developed so the data gets
standardized as it comes in from each
institution
and um the link to that is here
um so again i hope um the n3c folks will
come back and tell you more i have to
say i i've actually one of uh
our master's students has an interest in
working with um
atypical mycobacterium infections in
covet 19. so i'm gonna
i'll be his mentor and get to uh play
around in the
data enclave a little bit myself um i
mentioned open safely
again the reason why i like i i find
this project
interesting is they they were really
able to show all the risk factors that
we
now know all too well about um
complications and mortality from covet
19
higher age groups um co-morbid
conditions
certain ethnicities and um
you know fortunately this demonstrates
the value of having large
standardized data sets and um there will
probably be a lot to learn especially as
we start
uh carrying out uh effective treatments
immunizing the population and so forth
so i i will follow those studies
another area of interest to those of us
in informatics is open science
so making scientific information as
accessible as possible
um covet 19 has actually tested
uh that approach i think we're all still
firm advocates of open science but we've
seen some of the limitations
and part of it has to do with the
politics and the 24-hour news cycle
so as a result um things
make it into the news cycle they may be
poor quality research
there may need to be media there may be
that may lead to media hype
all the partisanship we have political
partisanship
and and that has led to proliferation
of outright pseudoscience conspiracy
theories
about the virus about certain types of
treatments and so forth
part part of the problem has been
exacerbated by something that we think
is a great thing in open science which
is pre-prints so
we no longer have to wait until an
article is
accepted to share it with our colleagues
we can put it on pre-print servers it
has a url so people can get to it
but the pre-print servers have been
inundated with
mixed quality research some good some
really bad
quality research um and in fact not only
that
um journals have been quick to accept
papers to get the word out
um and then now unfortunately though
there's a growing list of retracted
papers where
either the researchers themselves or
others may find real
challenges in in the research and some
of you may enjoy the
retraction watch blog that
deals with retracted papers we know that
information out there i mean we've known
this problem about the world wide web
almost since the web started the
variable information quality
one analysis looking at covid19
information found that in general it was
better on
oregon.edu sites than com but there's
plenty of variation
um the also um another challenge of
science with covid19
is that the information um uh
there's just this quick reaction we got
to do a clinical trial for this do do it
for that without a lot of coordination
um leading to waste and duplication as
noted by some writers
but still it's important to preserve the
integrity of clinical trials i think we
see that playing out with
vaccines and there is a role for
observational studies so
non-experimental studies but
those must also be
paired with or followed up by or based
on randomized control trials
we all know that covid19 has exposed
many fault lines
in our society issues around um
systemic racism income equality even
climate change
and um how has it done this um well
some not all these actually have to do
with coven 19 proper but it's exposed
these sorts of things
so for example as we um use more and
more
health care data to allocate resources
if we have health care disparities that
are baked
into data like shown in the study by
obermeyer in science
last year where african american
patients received
less care
and so that got baked into the data and
baked into the
machine learning algorithms that were
used to recommend allocations for care
we need to protect data there's lots of
people that want to monetize our data
maybe there's a role for that
but really the person the patient
really is the one who should have the
say over what is done with their data
we um many clinical algorithms have
historically used
race and sometimes that's appropriate
but
other times not there's a nice paper in
the new england journal of medicine
about that earlier this year
our old friend peter embi alumnus of the
program now
director of the regan street institute
um
wonders whether we need algorithmo
vigilance
not not only as algorithms are developed
but how they may
change when um there's they start to be
used which will necessarily change the
data
um and then a a covet 19 specific
this was a study looking at how relief
funding was allocated to hospitals
from the federal legislation
and it noted that
money was allocated based on historical
revenues now
we know that um the hospital's revenues
are not
necessarily indicative of of what they
do they may have higher revenues because
they have a different
payer mix and things like that so all of
these things i i mentioned
um just show that we really need to be
thoughtful about how not only how we use
data
but how we collect it what we choose to
measure what we ignore
and and i think the connection to cobit
19 is that
is that coven 19 has just exposed a lot
of these problems
so i am going to stop at this point
i um met my intended target for time so
i'm going to stop
my screen sharing so i can see the rest
of my
webex window and so i am
um happy to answer any questions
um looking at the um
question box uh i see a few announcement
type questions there
um and yes ben orwell did give a talk on
information blocking that i hope he'll
he'll give to us it's a complicated
topic
um i'll be happy to um
either people can type into the chat box
or
feel free to unmute yourself if you
have any comments or questions about
what i've talked about
this is always one of the challenges
with webex is that
i can't see any you other than than your
[Music]
names
well if there are no questions um we can
uh wrap up the session and um
i just want to make a reminder to those
attending the open house that will
resume um that session
at 12 30 and i'll be back to kick that
off and then we
we have a whole variety of speakers
including a panel of students from the
program to talk to you all
so um i want to thank you all um i want
to encourage other people to
um give your talks at this conference
so we can maybe go into some of these um
areas in more detail and um i will see
some of you
in the session uh in the open house
session that starts in about
um uh 12 minutes thank you everyone